porte quoi les ennemis à propos de
deux sosies ce qui pourrait te josy de
matt pokora on en a parlé accrochez vous
bien avant que franchement est ce on les
a vus aux répétitions ils sont
incroyables le luxe le à mon avis il
vient de camp mais à mon avis ça doit il
doit cartonné ce garçon il ya les
danseurs ça chante ça bouge ils sont
beaux vous êtes aux états unis boston
massachusetts bihboys ufc nord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'arrivais en maille
ans
[Musique]
ils ont parlé
on a crié
il ya ma muse te caresse pas
[Musique]
aussi
the
du gala
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
key
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
est ce qu'elle est
parce qu'il y est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
ah ah
merci les gars merci beaucoup jenkins
est ton émission c'est mon émission ce
soir
les deux côte à côte tu m'étonnes on
sent que c'est moi qui vais le
producteur
de
maputo l'arrivée photo la photo quand
t'as faim tu as des micros mais oui il
est là bas va changer car ça va c'est
pourtant c'est la voie des urnes m
almonte votre premier midi la donne
j'aime bien même le projet que la paix
américains
jadis la corse et dylan dit le dit ladd
d'accord dylan à quel âge as-tu 26 ans
26 ans est en pleine autoroute nationale
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fabien
mettay accroître la performance quand
même ben voilà on essaye de chaque
chaque rassemblement sur paris on essaie
d'être au top avec mon chorégraphe et
maxime de danse sa croyance u2 qu'en cas
de cork ouest de caen d'orco
je connais plein de gens comme ça
d'assérac ans et demi dans soeur sur sur
paris et j'ai même maintenant quelques
musiciens quand je fais quelques scènes
sûr quand un batteur et un guitariste en
fait ouais et donc voilà je suis saisi
un proche de la scène la jeunesse et
taper les tatouages qui a touché tous
les trois jours où les mêmes mais non
comment les mêmes que justin bieber
montre que nous nous montrer ce que
c'est de la ménagère ce que l'oeil il a
les atouts de partout n'ont pas le sens
nantes ap ap le tome sort c'est bien
dommage en effet tous les tatouages
c'est quand même assez incroyable tu
fais quoi dans la vie mes parents
dessine
alors moi dans la vie chez vous de
quoi dans la vie dans la vie je
travaille dans le bâtiment ou l'intérim
non c'est beaucoup dans le nettoyage
celles ci n'ont en rien à voir avec la
scène le public mais comment d'un coup
tu t'es dit je vais devenir ce que je
suis fan je suis fan déjà de base wen de
base et le j'ai connu les anciens sosie
à l'époque chris bieber ouais t'as dû
connaître quant à elle pas que les
nôtres carrière maintenant
il ya eu quand un entre-deux et moi je
suis nul après en fait vraiment appris
quand il le pure posture la la la la
comment ça paie de l'album avant wayne
justice et de chennegy justin bieber est
en tournée en ce moment et donc non
j'avais été à son concert où j'adore
conformément à des rencontres et non pas
du tout pas du tout c'est comme un oui
tu as de la chance unique dans sa loge
salon merci pas bon dans sa loge ouais
et alors c'était comment comment c'est à
dire c'était comment
j'ai vécu à peu près la même chose que
j'ai en michel mr ses rêves un coup de
feu n'avait rien à [ __ ] de moi qu'ils
connaissaient pas c'est non non il était
venu à tpm plus d'une fois justin bieber
way mais pas j'ai pas super se veut dire
papa fin moyennement eymard maire de
paris club moyennement aimé arriver
dessert trois heures de show lundi
mathieu douleur mois rim tête qui s'en
tapait un peu je peux l'entendre un peu
plus longtemps mais j'ai été un petit
peu déçu mais quand même tous les sosies
qu'on a eu depuis le début de ces
témoins je trouve que c'est le souhait
que c'est drôle qu'est ce que tu es et
tu fais quoi pour entretenir cette
ressemblance à mort plus de tatouages
les vêtements on essaie d'être
comme il est en ce moment avec les gants
ce mois une idée gourmande conserve ses
vêtements assez large ouais ça avec des
vêtements du centre et donc on essaye
vraiment de ces aucune chirurgie aucune
chirurgie il est où sa cote il vraiment
changé quant à la salle dernière tournée
a parlé j'étais pas tatoués ou que j'ai
fait beaucoup de photos à son à son
concert à lille que noah n'yat il pas
trop à paris et après avec les années
qui sait ce qui s'est passé justin temps
pose et moi j'ai voulu travailler sur
mon personnage et à faire des tatouages
et tout ça et après c'est vraiment
évolué ensemble sous le connais un petit
peu justin il est homosexuel
on peut rien dit alors ici j'arrive les
gens bien formés jean lalanne et de
mieux question est
juste il est marié
il a touché à tout sans jouer savoir
combien combien ça rapporte et le métier
de sova n'aime pas le métier même d'être
choisi comme ça pour l'instant
pour l'instant j'ai pas touché encore à
ce moment là tu fais des gars là tu ne
touches pas darwish prochain mais un
petit truc pour combien il ya là où tu
te produis pour une chanson prestations
comme tu es tu dépends de presse sur un
show sera show complet d'une heure à peu
près on a des fourchettes de prix à peu
près qui tourne entre 250 et 300 et les
danseurs ouais ouais on sait bien
pourquoi
n' est là qu est ce que tu comptes
restent estrosi ou est ce que tu as dit
appuyer sur ce qu'on a vu c'est à dire
créer tes propres compos tes propres
corée et faire une vraie guerrière toi
même pour l'instant non vraiment
j'essaye d'y rester encore longtemps
paraison gdg des petits problèmes en ce
moment où je peux pas avancer c'est
l'espoir qu'un stade g 20
l'aga khan a alors atteint ce qu'il faut
c'est que tu deviennes peut-être dans ma
loge tout à l'heure pour qu'on parle de
tous ces problèmes et que je t'aide à
avancer que je t'aide à avancer